there's a lot of online communities
anyone can start one you get a few
hundred people together there are so few
people who not only run in person events
but who do them well and if you can do
that it is an incredible competitive
advantage
[Music]
okay uh
sean's not here what are we gonna talk
about
uh a few things oh let me tell you
something sorry i asked you a question
that i interrupted you but let me tell
you something so
i'm doing something cool in 10 days
so
on the pod and on twitter i talked about
how i'm buying a piece of property and
i'm turning it into like a thing
like a like a hotel airbnb fitness thing
i had this guy i'm not gonna say who it
is yet because i haven't asked his
permission but basically he bought uh
like five 000 acres
in the south in a state in the south
let's say georgia
and he is turning it in to an airline
hotel
or an airline neighborhood soon with
hotels so basically they're putting an
airstrip in the middle of this piece of
property and then they're lining up
houses along it so you could buy a house
and then soon it's going to be a hotel
and then they're going to have an
airplane hangar there so for all
airplane enthusiasts you can keep your
plane there and take off and land on
this you know right outside your home so
it's basically like having a uh a house
on a golf course except instead of a
golf course it's an airplane
runway and hangar but here's the kicker
he asked me if i wanted to come check it
out and i said yeah sure he goes all
right meet me at the teterboro airport
in the like outside of new york on you
know january 25th and we'll fly my jet
down
so i'm flying private down i'm going to
go up to new york just to fly back down
just like it creates it but nice
isn't that that sick
so is this um
is it like super rural or is it uh kind
of just outside of a major metropolitan
area
it's an hour and a half outside of a
major area
got it so
and most of these people most of these
houses is this gonna be these people's
like full-time residents you think
no no probably not it's a lot of like
older people you don't have to be you
don't have to be like rich rich to
do this i think you have to like be able
to afford a 200 000
plane or something like that that could
be your hobby so you have to have some
money but it's not like gonna be
necessarily like incredibly wealthy
people
yeah so enough to afford like a cessna
or something like that and you just fly
in
and it's just somewhere to fly and then
you stay by your airport and just hang
out and chill yeah that's kind of neat
right
yeah it is kind of cool how much do you
think he's in on this project
um
uh i'll i'll say it and then if he says
i can't but uh nearly eight figures is
the money that he's had to use his own
money to do that and then he'll uh raise
some more money
and then how many houses and he was like
he was like oh it's just like a side
project and i was like
what that is huge that is
uh
how rich is your friend what does this
represent for him i don't know i just
met him um
like wealthy enough to be able to afford
that but not wealthy enough to like i i
like if he loses that it's not it's like
will be really bad
do you own any uh like vacation homes or
secondary homes or anything like that
well no no i own um
my house that i live in i own and then i
own some uh
uh like rentals and like a uh
now a vacant lot that i'm building a
house on to sell
but nothing like this no
plain vacation home no no i don't i
don't i think that vacation homes
only make sense
for me personally only makes sense to me
if i buy them and rent them out and so
if i can find a place in new york or
california that i like and i could rent
it out and make a profit then i would do
it so i met this guy the other day who
was a billionaire or close to a
billionaire and this person has
an apartment they don't live in new york
but they have an apartment there and
it's really fancy and then they have a
place in park city and they rent it out
when when they're not there and it pays
for itself and they're still like it's
like a wealthy person i think that's the
way to go as you
but not everyone's comfortable doing
that
it's interesting to me because this idea
that you're describing sounds like the
inverse of what i would want like i want
to be able to fly places
so that i could stay there like i want
to fly to new york so i can go to new
york but this is the opposite they're
setting up somewhere to stay so that
they can fly does that make sense well
it's not just that just imagine you're
like 65 years old and like you want to
like spend the weekend at this area and
you want to fly there and stay there and
hang out and then go on trips throughout
the day and just hang out with a bunch
of other airplane nerds that are like
you
yeah sure so it's like if you're like 65
and this is your passion i think i think
that people who are into this are
so into it that they just want to be
around other people who are into it
yeah i think there are a lot of
opportunities like this as people as
more and more people because it sounds
like this is mostly retirees but i think
you could also do it towards
remote workers
of just like
people have lived places for no
particular reason in the past and i
think as people can now choose where
they want to live they're going to start
congregating more in
groups of like
i don't know group around their hobbies
or like vegans how they want to eat i
don't know like random niches i agree i
think that will happen too the the day
that new york allows short-term rentals
so in new york you're not allowed to
rent for under 30 days
um or you got to like jump through crazy
hoops but the data that's allowed i'll
be buying a place there
but not not until that's allowed oh okay
you want to talk about this uh elizabeth
holmes thing
yes i do
uh so you see you sent this to me you
want to give the back story
well let's see what happened yesterday
so uh yesterday you sent a post to me
and sean that you were on the front page
of hacker news yes
they had
go ahead i meant like what happened to
holmes yesterday
oh so elizabeth holmes uh convicted of
like three or four crimes um i don't
know if she's been sentenced yet but she
could serve she will serve years of hard
time
potentially up to 20 years
yes
well there's 20 is three three counts
that were
carry sentences up to 20 years and one
that carries up to five so i don't know
if those are additive or if it's only up
to 20 i don't know how that works but
yeah so
yeah and what happened yesterday it
actually happened on sunday night i got
a text from a friend who goes hey you're
on the front page of hacker news if you
don't go to hacker news it's basically
like reddit but like if i said reddit
for nerds
you would be shocked because reddit is
for nerds but this is like really for
nerds like nerd nerds and it's all like
computer nerds and of which i am one of
them and i uh
i got a text saying that my article that
i wrote in 2015
was on the front page of reddit or on
hacker news and it was getting which
means you'll get millions of visitors
and the headline to my article was
the coverage of theranos is utter
and i wrote this article
defending theranos theronos and
defending elizabeth holmes
and
it did not age well that article
but
let me explain what the article do you
have the article in front of you
i just want to talk about my favorite uh
like sub headline which is
you called it a minor pr hiccup
yeah
so i call this a minor pr hiccup so i
wrote this into so i was uh like 24 i
think or 25 when i wrote this so
whatever you know i've grown and i read
my writing i was like oh my god i i
wasn't bad then but i'm way better now
and so i was a little embarrassed but um
the article basically was written after
people accused holmes of at first doing
something wrong
and they were hating on her but
previously in the in the previous month
in the previous few years she was on the
cover of all these same magazines
and the point of my article
was on the on the on the surface it
looked like i was defending her and i
was defending her but what i really was
also doing and i say this in an article
is i was
defending this idea that like it's i
think it's nonsense and crazy that we
build these people up and say that
they're like the next
you know the next steve jobs or whatever
it is and we like want small businesses
to win and someone starts a business and
we want them to win but then once they
get really successful or potentially
like uh they're considered like a winner
we turn on them and we just hate them
just because they're doing something
like that seems really weird and they
talk funny or they look funny and i
thought that's so i stand by
that second half because now that's even
the whole anti takazi thing is even
bigger
but yeah i was wrong i i was so wrong
about her
yeah it's just you see so many cases of
a lot of these hit pieces that are
totally not fair to founders that
like your guard was up
enough that you didn't see that this was
the time that they were actually right
she fooled me man she fooled me she
she took you in with her deep voice and
those big eyes
dude she got me i was so important
here's why i was on board with it and
the reason why i was on board with it
is really a i can't decide if it's a
good reason or a bad reason and you tell
me so their biggest backer was tim
draper
i don't know tim but i used to be
friends with his son and his friend's
son billy is an awesome dude and from
what i've read about tim tim seems
amazing i know that he's like this like
high integrity very honest person he
seems like a great guy he don't party on
drink and he's known for like being one
of the first investors in spacex i
believe first investor in hotmail so a
bunch of these like really amazing
companies that helped found the internet
and create the internet and everything
and he was super on board with the
theranos for a long time and so i was
thinking
well there's no way that tim draper
would do something um or like would be
tricked by this because he obviously
didn't know but he's like there's no way
that tim would be tricked by this
and that's why i was like on board
yeah
and just to back you up uh just reading
from the article it's expected that a
young company that's attempting to
change a massive and archaic industry
will mess up it appears that theranos
made a bunch of mistakes and i'm not
defending their actions i'm also not
saying that the media shouldn't point
out the truths about theranos's mistakes
either you just go on to say
uh talk about how the the cycle kind of
flipped on him so
yeah i mean
it is true what you're saying but it is
still funny to have an article up
with that headline and i didn't delete
it on purpose so brown three years ago
someone made fun of me for that article
and i was like i'm not deleting that
well keep it up it's all right i got it
wrong if i'm gonna if i'm gonna take
swings i gotta let people see the misses
too
yeah absolutely
um
all right wanna go one more topic
yeah we got four minutes so
all right so you tweeted out something
that was pretty cool what was it
okay so
it was essentially we started a new
family tradition in my family this year
which is well and it was just my wife
and i doing it because
we we started we're going to try and
roll out to my siblings and my parents
didn't she make a presentation
yes so
what it is is that i decided it was kind
of my idea that at the end of the year
we're going to make presentations
about how the past year went and
essentially what our goals are for the
coming year in our resolutions and that
type of stuff and we're going to present
it at like a family board meeting it
could be a slide deck it could be like a
memo but it's essentially called the
board meeting the family board is
sitting there and you have to present on
your ear it looked like she was
presenting to a bunch of people
yeah it was just you it was yeah it's
just me oh my god
but okay so and i should say
we're not totally crazy like we did it
kind of funny all right i dressed up as
steve jobs
gold glasses uh i'm not criticizing you
i think it's cool i don't know
the wrong idea that we were like getting
hardcore going over our numbers like a
lot of it was was kind of funny it was
played for chuckles but it was a good
opportunity to just
reflect on what we've done and uh and
what we hope to do this year and and uh
and go over so what was the uh
did is that effective
yeah i mean some of the stuff so
let me read some of this stuff actually
um
because i do the same i do the same
thing
so
my
wife actually collects the stats and
your wife's pretty alpha right
yeah she graduated from
uh a top law school in the country and
then
for
georgetown
um
yeah it's good it's good law school and
then she works for a big law firm now
so she took stats she like tracks
all her mother stuff because we had a
baby last november
um
and so i couldn't believe some of the
stuff so like gallons of milk that her
body produced in 2021
350.
gross isn't that crazy how does that
make you see your body do that that is
crazy i know that's that blew my mind
350. my god so much there's so much so
you're trying that's all there is you
track how much milk your wife made
yeah she also kept track of how many
nights she slept on the floor in our
daughter's room because like sometimes
she wouldn't sleep and so 104 nights
almost a third of the year yeah she
slept on the floor in claire's room
um
the number of hours she spent nursing
her was 1800
um and then we wait 1800 in one year
yeah
wow man being a woman is so much harder
i know that that did help me realize
like wow that's just like that's another
job in addition to your job like holy
moly that's crazy what else
uh any others
yeah um
she counted the number of times my
daughter was obsessed with this book
monsters come out tonight which is
halloween book
she read it 62 times
why does she do all this your wife just
because she wants to show your kids
i don't know she's just compulsive
actually she is
she's the type of person where in the
morning she'll go do you know what today
is and i never know because she always
knows weird anniversaries in her head
she's like oh it's
it's ten months since this happened and
i'm like how do you know that um but she
like compulsively tracks little numbers
in her head so
she apparently tracks him on her phone
too dude your wife's rain man that's
sick she's like
like a lactating rain man that's love
that
i might have to delete that i don't know
i'll have to think hard before i decide
whether to publish an episode in which
we call her a lactating rain man
um that's cool so what do you mean it's
a compliment though right you mean as a
couple yeah well it's neither a
compliment well the rayman is the
lactating thing is just fact
um the rayman thing is definitely a
compliment um
do you uh
do do you is she care is she earning
more than you as you start your business
yes
that's pretty sick right
it's nice i don't mind it
you uh
is she paying for everything
um no so she's actually still net
negative because she just graduated in
um
whatever in the summer and didn't start
school until october
um
so
i my goal is for us to never have a year
where she earns more than me not for any
like sexist reasons i just you know it's
a gold mine so i got to make more money
than her this year but yeah in the last
quarter of last year she made more money
than me so all right and that's actually
like i think there's a lot of guys who
are self-conscious about that
i uh feel the opposite i'm like i want
you like i want to be the lazier of like
i want her to earn more and just maybe
like not have to work
i am self-conscious about it i
i do like i'm happy for her to have a
career but like
it's not so much like uh self-conscious
about her making money but it is like a
little bit of like a
step it up you got to get your business
into a place where you're out earning me
like look what i'm out here doing you
know
that's sick though it's pretty sick i
think
you know how like there's articles that
talk about like your best financial
decision my opinion is the best
financial decision you can make of
course this is a good decision for a lot
of other reasons but the best financial
decision is marrying the right woman
amen
or picking the right spouse rather or
just staying married right did you have
you had the millionaire next door where
they're like no what did they say
it they look at all these factors that
like most millionaires have and this is
not silicon valley millionaires it's
like auctioneers and construction com
you know company owners and they say
like here are all these factors like
most have never purchased a suit for
more than i think it's like 800 most
have never paid more than 200 for a
watch
most in the vast vast majority of them
never got divorced
don't get divorced then that's great
crazy
and i think even if you get a prenup i
don't think that that like it it doesn't
does a prenup only work for the earnings
that you made before you got married yes
so then who cares in most cases exactly
because you get married i got married at
25 i was worth jack right and
all the money that i've made in my life
has been since i've got i've been
married 21 years so does a prenup cover
if you start a business and it's worth
nothing and then you get married and 10
years later it's worth a lot does that
do is this which one
does that count as
that i do not know what i do know is a
friend of mine got married got a prenup
and he had crypto
and he specified like this my hundreds
of bitcoin are excluded and they've gone
up in values and they're still excluded
but i don't know if company shares act
the same way
i would guess they would but you know
we'd have to get a lawyer on here
why are we streaming
[Music]
it's like the worst
sad topic no here's why we're covering
it because um ben's ben quit his job to
start a podcast a popular a podcast
that's going pretty well and he works
for us part time as a producer and he
his wife is a very successful lawyer and
i asked him i said you know like a lot
of men might be self-conscious about
that about your wife earning
significantly more than you how does it
make you feel and uh
i was just curious
has your wife ever earned more than you
rob
well that's a good question um well your
businesses are like family businesses
kind of right
yeah i mean she runs her own thing dude
i actually think i mean yeah so when i
left drip two years ago i sold a company
and then i left it in 2018 i didn't work
for six months but it's like so i wasn't
hurting anything but then even after
that like starting tiny seed i didn't
take a paycheck for a year and she was
making several hundred grand at her
business so yes she has but it's also
like yeah but i sold a comp i i think
i'm excused at this point you know
i uh my wife became a millionaire a
liquid millionaire before i did
that's awesome because it did by two
months
was it like stock or what would you she
worked at airbnb for a long time and
then it went public in december and i
sold my company in february so she beat
me by two months you didn't feel you
didn't feel bad about that at all did
you dude i was pumped for her i was so i
mean the way that everything is ours so
it was like frankly when she got paid i
was like oh i just got paid too i mean i
thought it was awesome um we're live now
by the way rob uh great are you okay
with that absolutely sir i'm always i'm
always i was born ready yeah so uh
this is rob walling rob you uh you i was
just on your pod like uh two weeks ago
did it go well
yeah i got a lot of positive feedback
actually what was interesting is someone
said a couple people said you guys have
real great rapport and i said which is
funny because we've never met it's not
like we're best friends but they said
you sounded like you were friends you're
naturals you know and i said i think
it's it's easy to have a podcaster on a
show because they're just entertaining
naturally and
i've been reading your work for like 10
years um and so or i forget how long but
basically ben we so this is ben ben
works with us um he's filling in for
sean today we uh i sent rob like an
email like in 2000 and i forget he like
pulled it up but i sent like my first
email to him like years ago saying how
much i loved his content and then i was
finally on his podcast like eight years
later so it worked out yeah and that
helps that familiarity certainly helps i
know that people who listen to my
podcast and then appear on it know what
to expect and they're able to to roll
with it which is why before coming on
here i i i've listened to your show on
and off over the years but like i
listened to like the last four episodes
just so i would have some familiarity
what did you think
i think they're great you gotta get a
show here i think you should change the
name of the show is what i think you
should i think the names off the name is
horrible i know it's tough and man i
have you know my podcast is startups for
the rest of us which i still like but it
feels long now and i've debated whether
to to change it have you guys actually
considered it because i'm curious what
would go what would need to go into a
name change the problem is is
we considered it like a year ago when we
were smaller but then we were like back
then we were like uh we're too big back
when we were did that we we were at like
three or four hundred
thousand units a month and or a visitor
or um listeners a month and we were like
oh but we're too big it already is stuck
now we just in december we crossed two
million uh lessons a month and we're
like
now we're definitely like we're
definitely too big and darmesh who is
the founder of hubspot who now owns a
podcast he was like you gotta change the
name and i'm like darmash it's way too
late and he's like no it's not and so he
thinks we should do it i think it's too
late in the game frankly i think a bad
name sometimes is a good is a good thing
but the name is quite horrible and i
feel embarrassed to tell my barber and
stuff and they're like well what's it
about i'm like
i'm not sure but not much but yeah it's
not about making your first million
that's for sure yeah it's not get rich
quick it's like a real business podcast
and that's that's the thing is
since you have subscribers because what
i've thought about is like let's say we
change the name of
you know
of startups for the rest of us
i think i just changed it in the rss
feed i change it with apple and spotify
and then it just propagates i think
people i need new line you know liner
art or whatever i think people be
confused for a few weeks
and i guess all the incoming links
would say sort of the rest of us are my
first million but aside from that i just
don't know the backlash it's it's
it's less of like changing the name of a
company is really hard right because of
the brand you've built but changing them
a podcast i think is so i i'd like to
think it's simpler but i've never done
it our friend nathan uh started this
company called convertkit which is
amazing and i'm an investor in and it
was crushing and he changed the name to
something i forget what he changed the
name
yeah which
apparently does that mean something
offensive in hindi it wasn't offensive
but it was it it it has like a spiritual
meaning and so the back he had backlash
right and it was about cultural
appropriation was the kind of phrase
that was used yeah it's like a it's a
word in a different language and people
were like you can't name your company
that and i he's not a he's like at the
time was probably like a 50 company they
probably did some research but they
mostly like just probably read the
definition in a dictionary thought it
sounded cool and then like a week later
they changed it back to convertkit which
i think is a great idea convertkit's a
good name
yeah it's
that's that's the other thing with the
name change is okay so you're going to
change my first million what are you
going to change it to because naming is
really hard right are you very hard i
know some people who are really good at
it most people are not including myself
i struggle with naming i always go too
literal we would hire i would hire one
of those like naming firms i actually
think that i think a naming firm is
actually a great idea
yeah at this level and at the at the the
kind of reach that you have and the
stakes and the race i guess the
resources you have it would be a
no-brainer yeah really good i don't i
don't know do you listen to tropical nba
podcasts by chance yeah i like those
guys yeah they had a really good kind of
lower budget naming person i say lower
budget let's say five grand 10 grand
versus you know you can pay a hundred
grand or more um she was super sharp it
was such a good episode and she had like
an ebook on how she does it and i was
intrigued by that just because
look you and i are going to be putting
out new whether we rename things or
putting out new stuff for the rest of
our lives so
how do we get better at this right
that's something i want to do
yeah what were you saying ben
i i you actually answered the question i
was gonna ask which is how much is a
naming service but there you go but i
mean you know i i think like the thing
about my first million
like you said sometimes a bad name is a
good name because the thing is it forces
someone to react like someone has to
have an opinion about my first million
they might not like it but they're not
gonna just like forget about it they're
like oh what's that but dude my
companies are called the hustle horrible
name hustle con horrible name once i'm
at a conference on content i call the
con con no a meetup series called pizza
and 40s uh our subscription service
called trends like i'm not good at like
i i like i've done trends is good the
hustle has been bad
the rest of them are tough because the
hustle hustle now has this negative it
has for several years this hustle
culture right has a negative connotation
so i guess if you're leaning into that
at least it gets attention but it's a
tough one to do so rob how do you
describe your your who you are
in a professional sense how do because i
was going to introduce you but you're
you're pretty eclectic that i don't even
know how to the proper way to do it yeah
i mean bottom line man i used to be a
software developer and then i didn't
want to work for other people so i
started startups and first it was i mean
in 2006 it was downloadable software
there really wasn't sas and then it it
became sas right that's what you do now
if you're in software um so i became a
founder serial entrepreneur launched a
few acquired a few and
along the way started blogging about it
as you know as you were saying i wrote a
couple i've written three books about
bootstrapping startups i bootstrapped
everything i never raised funding i'm
not anti-funding i'm not i think funding
has a time and a place but i am anti the
narrative that in order to start a
startup you have to raise funding
because i that is just not the case i
think one percent of companies one
percent of tech companies need funding
and the other 99 really shouldn't
shouldn't do it
so around 2011 then started a podcast
and then
uh no that's 2010 and then 2011 started
my events called microconf and um
and then just a couple years ago
launched an accelerator for sas
bootstrappers so you um i wanted to go
to microconf years ago i remember that
and i didn't have enough money to to go
so i'm gonna have to go soon but how
what were the name of some of your
software companies i know drip and can
you reveal like how big some of these
grew to
yeah
drip crew into well i mean drip is tens
of millions now but i sold it in in 20
what year was that 2016. grew it to a
few million bucks before i sold it
you grew to three three three million
dollars a year in revenue and then it uh
now does tens of millions of dollars
oh yeah absolutely i mean this is email
email service providers or really any
type of sas
um
if you double down on it like and you
stick around for a long time this stuff
just it compiles it it goes up every
month if you're doing it right do you
regret selling it no never never a day
have i woken up and thought i really
wish i was still working on that like i
learned we were a team of 10 when we
sold it
and
i learned what i needed to learn and it
was enough money that i never had to
work again and that had been a goal i
was 41 maybe when i sold it and that was
a
lifelong goal you know to have enough
money to not work again yep and i knew i
would i knew i would work well what was
your number
well i don't want to tell you how much
no but
you don't tell me what you sold for but
like in like when you said my goal is to
earn this much like what was the
threshold of not having to work oh
that's interesting you know when i was
25 i just thought it was millions i
never actually calculated it and then as
i got into my 30s i started saying well
what's this four percent rule thing that
you hear about in personal finance right
and i actually think the four percent
rule is um i think you need to
be you need to be a little more cautious
so it's about three three and a half
percent so then
the rule is if you need if you want a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year to live on
and you have five million dollars in the
bank then the idea is that if you do the
four percent roll you can take out 200
grand a year and
never um touch the principal because
stocks and bonds and other investments
or are do and inflation are working
there so a three percent rule would give
you about 150 grand so i'm not using my
numbers but you get the idea so it
quickly became apparent to me that when
i was in my 30s of like i think
somewhere it's somewhere between 5 and
10 million i think is most people's
number depends on where you live depends
on how you live um but i think anything
north of 10 is like
like
it is excess i'll say that i i'm north
of 10. and i and i feel like i
my life didn't change there was some
point in between five and ten where it
was like yeah that's enough you know i
still like having the money and i do
things with it but um
definitely
it's not like i would have had to work
again even with a major stock market
downturn or something that's pretty cool
three million with ten employees is a
pretty sick business when it's software
it was very efficient we were also
really i mean i was bootstrapped i
should have raised a round i should have
raised a seed round because it was way
stressful and i was uh i burned out
pretty hard on it and that was part of
there were several factors into selling
for me and i'm curious if you you know
have talked about why you sold as well
but for me it was like number one if i
can never if i can have enough money
that i control my own destiny for the
rest of my life that was a big win it
was the only way i would sell that was
the only reason why i sold is it's just
like take the cash off now you can do
anything i mean i started a damn startup
accelerator right so i we fund uh
bootstrap sas founders
i'm not gonna make money from that and
that's a five to ten year play to make
real money right to actually get the
carry back i take a salary but it's like
a token what i could be making somewhere
else um
and so
i can now do play long ball with it
because i'm not thinking oh how am i
gonna you know how am i gonna do my big
score i never wanted to be worth my goal
was never i need 100 million or i need a
billion it would be i'd be fine with
that but that's not that wasn't the goal
it was to have that freedom i sold to
have that but
i wish
the thing about my company is that i
loved it i mean i still i'm still here
and i love it um like i hate it and i
hated uh like there was days where i'm
like this sucks i hate media i hate
dealing with people of course i had like
those normal things but like the thing
is is that like i started my company
because i was just blogging for fun when
it didn't make money and i didn't
actually think it was going to make
money and now that i have something i
still do this because i just am a
compulsive and i love it and so i love
my company i just
wish
i wish i was wealthy that i didn't have
to sell it do you know what i mean yep
and so because now i know i'm gonna go
and start it again one day you're gonna
have to start something and that one you
won't have to sell right you'll be in a
position where you can decide to to do
it or not and you can make bigger bets
because if it goes to zero
it's not like you're sitting where i was
in 2015 where it's like i am literally
worth
millions and millions of dollars on
paper
and i have
actual liquid net worth about 400 grand
in retirement savings between my wife
and i and i have about 50 000 in the
bank and our house which had no equity
because it was you know it had gone down
or whatever so that was it so i was like
i felt way overexposed to
something tragic happening when you are
doing three million in recurring revenue
um i'm not sure if how you do like if
people pay up front or what what not but
like i've seen convertkit's numbers like
all the public stuff that they reveal
and they're they didn't have a
significant amount of cash in the bank
was your was your thing the same way
where absolutely wait wait because like
tenant you think 10 employees making 10
uh make it 3 million like oh you should
have like plenty of money
but what was the truth
the truth is that growth
choose just
destroys cash like no matter how much
cash we made
i've i was
spending on aws bills i was spending it
with send grid i would hire another
contractor i would hire another employee
the moment we would grow by 10 grand in
a month let's say of a monthly recurring
and i'm like great now i can hire
another engineer because oh my god we
are understaffed so at 10 people we were
way understaffed um
and
yeah i'm trying to think uh and that's
where like my decision at that point was
i'm either going to raise an angel round
like a seed round
or we should sell it and that was that
was the decision of do we double down on
this business for another
two to four years or am i ready to
to you know make make that choice of
letting it go and that so that i was a
drip user who owns it
um well what's interesting so
leadpages bought it leadpages had raised
um 38 million in venture and
they
it's actually a parent company right
called avenue 81 incorporated that owned
leadpages and then
acquired drip so there's two products
under one umbrella well pretty soon
within the avenue 81 you know ceo
realized the opportunity here is drip
like drip is a multi-billion dollar
opportunity whereas landing pages are
you know the whole market at the time
was 80 million maybe 100 million and
that's that sounds like a lot to us but
they're venture backed so they need to
get to billions in valuation so they
actually sold off lead pages and the
company is now trip
so drip owns drip now you know what i
mean like it's it was a turnaround i
don't know if you i don't know if you
ever heard that this happened with best
buy where they acquired a greek squad
and now like best buy would not exist
without geek squad because that was like
all their net profit through the you
know last 15 years that essentially that
essentially happened with drip they just
refocused the whole team they had 170
employees and
i got to start hand picking people from
the leadpages team and pulling them over
to help grow the team so when i left
there were 100 and some people working
on trip do you feel like see
remember like when you're a kid and used
to date someone and then you see her
with another guy and you like feel just
like that that jealous you feel like
anger and jealousy and you're sad do you
do you still have that do you have that
emotion when you see drip
i don't
and
but but i will say that there have been
some things that have happened that have
that i haven't been happy with so they
like raised prices and they didn't do it
very well right after i left like a few
months after and i was like you guys are
better than like i would have done that
so differently and if i was in the room
i would have said don't do they just did
it really fast they didn't grandfather
you know they just made kind of all the
101 mistakes and that sucked and i and
then there was a huge backlash against
drip which is part of my legacy like
drip drip is you know what it's like the
hustle will always you will always be
the founder of the hustle right and i
will always be the co-founder of drip
they've messed with the ui
they've reshaped it and stuff so when i
go in now i'm a little bit like ugh i
liked it the old way but but i don't
feel it's not the ex-girlfriend thing
it's more of a i did have to let it go
you know and just and just
let it go i still use it i i mean i'm in
it every day it's such a good tool
do that that's a good sign do you um
and then microconf was that a big
business because i when when i started
hustlecon i like research you guys to
steal ideas but like also like to make
sure it's a good business and i was like
well rob's pretty savvy and he's doing
it so like yeah i could probably make a
profit off this yeah yeah it was
definitely you know it was a side
project like a hobby all this time right
until about two years ago where when i
left drip i had this big decision of
like
i have this podcast at the time i had a
co-host with the podcast i'm solo now um
had microconf
do i sell all of that
i literally thought of just leaving the
whole entrepreneur like blogging
podcasting thing
and going and like i was going to
acquire a tabletop gaming the second
biggest tabletop gaming website all
right what's the tabletop yeah you know
like settlers of catan or like dungeons
and dragons so it's like not like a
board game is monopoly right but then
there's like the levels above that of
complexity and stuff and so which are
booming right now huge well covet helped
but also they're just they're super
popular and so i was like that's a hobby
of mine and i was like i really want to
do it and then i started talking to the
owner of this site who's great great
dude
and i'm like what are your numbers and
he started giving me the numbers and i
was like
this makes no money this may and he's
like yeah dude tabletop games make no
money like that you know there's the few
there's the katan and there's d there's
like 10 or 20. everything else kind of
is i mean i'm over generalizing here
because certainly there's other but it's
not like startup like we are so spoiled
with startups where we don't manufacture
physical things
and and you don't have returns and you
don't have excess inventory and you
don't have a warehousing and all that
stuff and the profit margins are thin
and etc etc so that's when i double down
um
on all of that and so yes your initial
question was is micro company good
business yes will we sell let's see
we'll sell seven feet like low seven
figures like a million million and a
half dollars i think in top line this
year maybe somewhere in that range i
need to look at the budget you can tell
that i have someone running it because i
should know that i would know that
number if i was actually like
will you be able to and could
if you do 1.5 i would i would hope that
you probably do like
300 or 400 in profit
i think so
although here's what we do see
we
are not running it
as a profit machine we are running it
almost it's become like a service to the
community
um and so we run a bunch of the events
at break even or lost like our local
events are where we go to san jose or
atlanta or austin texas we do a one-day
event those tend to break even or lose
money and we're doing it to try to just
expand like the mission is to increase
the number of independent startups in
the world right that's what we want to
do bootstrap startups used to be the
term but it's like it's not solely
bootstrapped some people raise small
amounts of money
and to do that we got to get the word
out and so we run it at a
you know 10 to 20 profit net profit
margin and we could make more money we
used to make more money um five years
ago or whatever but there's just no need
to at this point that's a pretty sick uh
side like a good hobby
it was good it wasn't bef when i still
had drip we weren't doing a million
because we were you know we're going to
do 15 events this year when we were when
i was running drip we were doing three
but they were big they were big events
we would have trying to think of what
our top line
revenue was even and i was happy you
know let's say half a million 600 grand
across three events so it was good but
it's a brand right man it's like the
first year
we in 2011 we went to sell tickets
and we were like we're gonna sell 200
tickets at 800 a piece or 500 a piece
and we sold like 70 at like five years
terrible and second year
everyone's like you're going to make
money off sponsors and yes you will it's
going to take you two or three years
though to trust you yeah and we almost
what i didn't realize with events was
they buy like a year in advance so like
our first sponsorships were like 2k a
piece then we started getting the 50k
and 100k but they booked a year in
advance and i was like what
so like it's a it's a crazy business
yeah i personally wouldn't i kept saying
to my i had a co-founder with that and
then our event producer and i kept
saying i don't want to be in the events
business right we we had one event and
then we expanded it to two because we
wanted to do one in europe
and then we expanded to three because we
went at an earlier stage event and i
kept saying i don't want to be in the
events business and they kept telling me
that's the business this is an events
business you've started one you know but
i did it more as a community i wanna i
always thought of it as a community
because that's like microconf has an
online community and youtube channel and
all that stuff
look ben you look like you're about to
say something
no no i was oh you're laughing uh
yeah i was just laughing
who who starts a a business an event
business and doesn't know it's an event
business but uh dude that was the same
way i started when i started high school
i was like this is this is stupid this
is just a means to an end we're getting
out of this immediately and then it's
like uh
it's
it's kind of like when you see all your
friends starting software companies
you're like dude events are embarrassing
why would i want this like this is
stupid it doesn't it's too hard but then
once you get a little more confident in
yourself and you're like well if i
accept it for like for what it is it's
actually pretty neat
um yeah and there's nothing like it like
in this even let's say pre-covered from
2011 until until this year over the last
10 11 years
there's a lot of online communities
anyone can start one you get a few
hundred people together there are so few
people who not only run in person events
but who do them well and if you can do
that it is an incredible competitive
advantage and not even that we have that
much competition but it is
it's not just like i'm gonna run a
business and make money it's like the
community of microcomp is so tightly
knit and it's because we meet in person
you know what i mean you just you have i
mean you you've experienced this where
you go to an event you meet someone in
person and we the retention rate was 60
or 70 so you come back to the next year
and everybody kind of knows each other
and then you get new blood and you know
so there was
it built a way better community than if
we did not have in-person events so
because your job this is your career you
see a lot of like crazy software
companies some of which maybe aren't
necessarily huge but they are could be
surprising because you're like i cannot
believe someone's making this work and
you probably are able to spot lots of
opportunities
we asked you if you knew of we asked you
ahead of time and i'm curious if you
ever think of any any software companies
where you see and you're shocked at that
this is like a problem that needed to be
solved
yeah i see a bunch so i have some i have
some both ideas that i haven't seen
implemented that maybe we can dig into
later
yeah we'll do both of those yep but
there
so i'll talk about a couple so tiny seed
is a startup accelerator i run and so as
a result you know we've had across what
four batches set right four batches
we've had
two or three thousand applicants so i've
seen a lot of sas companies come through
wow and
what i've uh i've been surprised by a
ton of them let me just look at one
right here
so
crm or
kind of customer interactions applied to
any niche and the smallest niche you can
imagine
so like home improvement contractors
the founder of builder prime is the size
sas we funded it with tinyseed and he
had a home improvement
project and he said the experience
dealing with the contractor the
contractor was fine but the
communication was like text and then
email and it was anytime there's a bunch
of text and email that can be a product
what was the name bill the what builder
prime builder prime builder prime yep
and so it's in essence i think he might
call it crm for yeah he calls it best
crm but really
it's not only the sales process but then
it's the communication during a home
improvement project
and so like shouldn't you i would say
well shouldn't couldn't use base camp is
it like project management or could i
use microsoft project like online right
because you could but it's like no this
is a strongly typed version of that that
is completely built for their needs
how's this going
it's going really well i can't disclose
revenue but um i'll say anyone in who's
in batch two any of those companies are
gonna be you know mid six figures into
seven figures right
the um founder of hubspot brian halligan
came on the pod and he told us that when
they i i'm gonna paraphrase the story i
might get a little bit wrong he said
that when they first started hubspot
they were like at a fork in the road and
not sure which way they were gonna go
and for a minute i think they even
created it and even had some sales but
they were like well let's like hubspot
is a crm but then let's create like lost
spot so it's like uh hubspot just for
lawyers so instead of like making it one
for everyone we're going to make an
individual one for different industries
and so let's create law spot and just
get lawyers to use it and that's kind of
basically what this company builder
prime is because you would say like why
can't you just use hubspot why can't you
just use assa whatever you wanted
whatever it is
i understand and so
all right this is a cool company how big
is a team on this
what what ben
my other question is um like
do you have any companies rob that you
work with that are building apps on top
of salesforce or hubspot that are like
building in those ecosystems or do you
think
they should always go the direction of
builder prime and just build their
entire own ecosys ecosystem
we have
one who is built on heroku
one who's
kind of built he has a wordpress plug-in
kind of built on wordpress they're
actually doing really well it's castos
it's podcast hosting they're they're
into seven figures but there's no you
know so the thing is is with building on
hubspot or salesforce there's this
platform risk right because i had an
angel investment that was doing really
well was built on shopify was a shopify
app and they started killing it and then
shopify came and knocking and said
you got to start paying us big chunk
your revenue or we shut you down i mean
really you know i i would say it's shady
but it is what it is it's platform
risk right
um so that's where we have to be aware
like if you go to sell a sas company and
you're solely built on top of a platform
you
sell for a lower multiple than if you
were on your own so
as a result
what we say when folks come in and apply
and say hey i'm only on heroku or if we
see shopify apps come through
we had to have seen salesforce apps come
through i don't remember hubspot one to
be honest
but what we say is cool it's not a
non-starter but how are you thinking
about this are you building for what
other platforms are you building for how
do you escape that because by the you
know when you're 500 grand a year no one
cares when you're 5 million a year
on a platform they notice and that
there's there's a danger there
that's that's pretty cool that's
interesting i i mean i knew that was
true but i didn't know that shopify
could change the prices that they
charged
seen it happen firsthand yeah what else
is just go ahead yeah there's another
one um
this one's interesting it's called
scraping b
and the cool part about them is they are
public with their revenue so i can
actually at least give an idea so they
crossed a million dollars in annual
recurring uh just two three months ago
and if you look at what it is is it's
they allow you if you want to
um
scrape the web right if it's like well i
want to get all you know the products
off of this particular e-commerce site
you can go in and it's not a gui like
you need to write a little bit of code
but then they have all the servers that
allow you to get around being blocked by
apis or whatever
and when you think about this idea it's
it's like well that sounds like a nice
little 510k a month idea right
they're doing north of uh you know
probably a hundred hundred grand a month
right now i haven't looked at their
revenue recently like it says
yeah
it's two employees it's the two founders
they're doing it's crazy we're
encouraging them to hire actually
because
here's the problem let's say they wanted
to sell
i'm not saying they do but if they
wanted to that's a problem like they
would they would be worth more if they
or a team of five or ten than if they're
only two
because they're making a bunch of profit
but it's there's risk there right do
they is this like uh one of those uh
public revenue things on like the bare
metrics or whatever you know i think
they just disclose it on twitter
pierre to wolves yeah and it's like
every couple months he'll say when they
hit a milestone he'll be like we hit
this and
um the co-founder i mean co-founders
pierre and kevin are really cool and
transparent and they talk a lot about
its content and seo and they have grown
crazy fast i believe and my memory
serves me correctly that when they
joined tiny seed they were at 4k a month
and this was
two years ago tops
18 months two years i'd you know so it's
like to go from 4k to
ostensibly what 90k 100k they're in that
range a month um
pretty cool
these guys should raise money maybe
yeah they should they could if they
wanted to it's up to them right but the
valuations right now for a company
that's growing quick that has a million
in revenue is like 50 to 100 million
dollars yeah it's nuts i know so like if
you could raise five million dollars and
just do five i mean that's kind of
interest that'd be that'd be easy to
justify
right but it depends on the founder
right it's like that's one of the things
that a lot of bootstrappers they don't
want to get on that once you raise that
money now you're on the venture track
right and it's like i gotta raise every
month
yeah but we're different tiny seeds for
bootstrappers and so with tinyseed folks
can run their business and take profits
out we actually fund llc's
and they can take profits out if they
want or they get paid
we get paid if they take profits out
because we we
you know buy a percentage of their
equity
so
basically if they take dividends out we
pros you know serve pro rata in those or
if they were to sell the company again
we own stock so or units and llc's so we
get that percentage uh when they sell
but is that actually going to be
profitable for you you think more so
than um trying to get trying to do the
traditional model where you throw
at the wall in 10 maybe works right well
we we are still in the traditional model
of we've funded six 59 60 companies to
date and we will fund another
100 and we have enough money right now
to fund another 120 150 in the next
three years so we are still in that
model of making a lot of bets
what we're what we see is that our bets
like i don't think we will have a
billion dollar outcome i just don't see
that being reasonable i think we have a
lot of
10 to 50 10 to 100 million outcomes and
the num we've run a bunch of models and
in fact if you go to tinycity.com
thesis
you will see my co-founder is a data was
a data scientist phd computer science
and we ran a bunch of back testing on
anonymous sas data
uh i think it was several thousand
companies and looked at our our funding
approach versus you know what it would
return and it will return
venture-like returns with
i believe lower downside risk because we
invested we invested the early stage at
low valuations in essence wow what else
is interesting to you
um yeah you want another another company
no tell me what ideas do you think
there's opportunities in yes all right
so here's so i always when i start with
ideas i'm i'm such a b2b sass founder
right so i start with the problem right
and so first any time i see someone
doing something in excel or or a google
sheet i think to myself that could
that's an idea right if you take it or
if there's a bunch of email you know or
text back and forth um those are because
it's communication or it's just storage
there's a couple things
that um
i'm pretty fascinated by so
one is
podcast apps are doing quite well like
we're in riverside now we've funded i'm
invested in squad cast which is a
competitor of riverside um
both of them we're using riverside now
we use squad cast we use zencaster
i was with them before yeah with
squadcast and then of course podcast
hosting right there's castos and lib liz
libsyn and and others
and
i think even podcast editing like alex
we use i use audacity and then my editor
uses adobe something or other but like
ali2 ali to use podcast editing in the
browser so like the stack starting to
get there we have disparate tools to do
things but when hubspot launched so i so
i know darmash right darmesh and i were
bloggers and speakers we met at bos in
2008 or something so i remember when
hubspot launched and
i remember thinking
but all of these things exist like in
the early days hubspot was like it was
like a a blog i think plus a marketing
website plus google analytics plus i
don't remember what something email
capture form or something like that it
was very simple but i was like i could
but i remember saying darmesh but i
could build that you know with mailchimp
plus wordpress you know and he's like
yeah but business owners don't want to
do that they want a bundle and he was
right
i think and he was right i said they're
public and where you guys are an amazing
company i think of the same thing with
podcast production where i right now i
mean i've been running a podcast for 11
years and i have you know people helping
with it and
i literally am in notion
dragging this thing over here and then
sending an e that sends an email to my
producer to do something that we then
log into castos to upload you know what
i mean it's like where's the hub spot
for that where's the bundling of the
podcast stack i have a strong opinion i
have two strong opinions the first
is i'm almost certain
no
i'm partially certain that for the most
part podcasting software and podcasting
tools is a horrible business because a
few reasons very few podcasts are
successful and most all of them are
broke
here's my here's the counterpoint to
this right because i would like to
because i am an investor so i see the
numbers all right
um
squad casts doing several million a year
in revenue and they're not doing it on
the fly fishing podcast think of the
three avatars for
a podcast there there's the hobbyist my
dungeons and dragons podcast my fly
fishing
and they're gonna they're broke and
they're gonna pay nine bucks a month
right and they're gonna churn like crazy
because they're gonna start it's too
much work all right
then there's the next tier up which is
startups for the rest of us i'd say my
first million is in that where it's like
a single show but if i go to pay
a hundred dollars a month for
squad cast riverside 100 a month for
coasting it's not a big deal to me right
and i don't think it is to you there so
it's not nine dollars but for you it's
like a hundred i think if i were to say
oh my first movie should pay 500 a month
for each of these you start to feel like
i'm not sure that's worth it but there's
a number there okay so there's a and
they and we don't churn i mean i've been
doing it for 12 years you guys have been
doing it for several it's like the the
the s b of of podcast it's the smb that
actually sticks around there's hobbyists
there's smb then there's one level up so
there's
i heart radio there's espn's podcast
there's the kevin smith podcasts
smodcast right there is kara swisher has
a whole network gimlet media npr like
once they especially once they went
remote
that's the enterprise but how many of
those are there because for example like
vox i think vox was trying to sell their
cm like it's all media companies are
like oh we built this proprietary
technology to like get our articles
shared better and like things like that
and like cool i would love that
technology but they want to go out like
washington post is doing this they want
to go out and sell their software and
i'm like how many media
companies could pay 100 grand a year for
software most media companies are broke
and so that's my same thing to
podcasters but all right i agree those
exist i want to be i need to be
convinced that there's like enough of
them
ben was going to say something we should
let him
say
i was blown away so we
got a pitch from one of these
recording companies one of the ones that
rob mentioned i won't say which but i
assumed that the pro tier that rob was
talking about would be like 10x what a
normal plan was and it was like 100x it
was like
it was like plus a month
for um
a month a month a month
for some of these features
yeah and um
the squad i was blown away i could not
believe it i was blown away but anyways
you know it's worth it for for a lot of
people so anyway for that type of
company you don't need that many
customers i think is is maybe the point
really do you get crazy amounts of
features with
dollars a month
i mean
they're cool they are cool features
they're cool features
wow that is crazy
that does sound high i will admit that's
crazy that's where you don't need that
you don't need that many okay so
podcasting is you're saying it's a good
business because there's actually enough
customers
to to make it work right yeah yeah and
podcasting has this other thing that
that is
i think undervalued or just not talked
about enough it's this concept of a dual
funnel or a split funnel where
you have you know who else has this is
um
electronic signature e-signature has
this where you have this super wide
funnel there's either free users or very
inexpensive users
on the low end and so a lot of people
use it thus you build a brand and you
just have five thousand ten thousand
customers whatever uh
some are just users summer customers you
also if you have any type of viral loop
that's amazing right you send the link
to squad caster riverside you send a
link to get a document signed oh a
little bit of virality but then on the
top end with the signature similarly you
have realty mortgage brokers who
i need 8 000 documents a month signed
and suddenly that's at 10 20 30 grand a
month that dual funnel is incredible
because when if you're just enterprise
then you're enterprise right and it's
like oracle in the old days it's like
all right so we need to close 500 deals
this whole year but each deal is a
million or two million bucks right i
mean that's it's like these massive
deals
and it's just this grind of enterprise
sales but when you have the low end
funnel and the high end funnel it's um
it feeds on itself and it helps you have
a more stable business the companies
that are able to charge uh six figures a
year in software do you think that a lot
of times their software is actually
better than the five dollar a month
tools that are in the same category but
for different people
like is it is it you know if a coup if
it's five dollars a month versus five
hundred thousand dollars a year is it
actually a thousand times better
no it's not and i would it's not um
five dollars a month i would say or
whatever a more accurate one is like you
know is if i'm paying 250 250 a month
versus 25 000 a month let's say that's
it's a 100x difference
those are probably relatively similar
and in fact a lot of the pricing advice
we give to our founders um or i give on
the podcast as well is
the moments
someone approaches you a potential
customer and says
cool we like your software we need to
redline your terms of service or we need
uh to invoice with pos or we need single
sign-on or we need a salesforce
integration or we need there's there's
this whole list of things that instantly
should trigger
you should pay about a hundred times
more that your price should go because
the sheer headache of dealing with
procurement and going through that
process and the maintenance and all the
you know the interaction
it's not that the software is better
it's that the
the time and the headache and the pain
of making that sale and maintaining that
customer is um
that's where it's at right that's where
the money spent but is it that hard to
like
uh do the single sign-on or like isn't
there is there not like an 80 20 thing
that you can do whereas like it works
for most high-end customers
well there's two things right it's are
we pricing on value because i price on
value right there's price you can price
on cost you can price on value what's a
third
i forget what the other one is anyways
but
certainly i'm not pricing my sas on cost
because i would have no margin right so
i'm going to try to price based on the
value and
um
i could build single sign on it's like
hey let's let everyone have it but it's
a trigger that that company has the
ability to pay and frankly are going to
get a lot more value out of it than a
one-person team using it right you know
it's like gimlet media versus rob
walling comes to
you know sign up for your podcast
recording it's like gimlet media should
pay a lot more than me not because they
they need that many more features but
they just should their whole business is
built on it and they're making millions
it matters more to them yeah
any other ideas that interest you at the
moment oh yeah um so i gotta be honest
man i mean this is not even a sas idea
i'm just gonna throw it out you know you
do you know the website examine.com
my favorite website out there yeah i
would put it in top ten i'm a pain i'm a
paying member there's a new one that i'm
looking at called uh
consumer
it's like examine.com but for uh
brands for vitamin brands anyway examine
his nutrition information you can trust
so i interviewed the founder
uh on my i love soul self he's great i
interviewed him on the podcast sherry my
wife's been friends with him for several
years since i met at an event so
had him on the show and i was fascinated
by it because i'm like
it's nutrition information you can trust
right and you know that but i'm saying
it for the audience
where is the examine.com for crypto and
nft like for web3 stuff because i feel
like there's so much crazy info out
there and there's so many opinions and
religious you know not truly religious
but like religious fervor and the and
the bitcoin maximalist and and it's
like
someone
can do this
right
in the business so let's talk about that
examine i've talked about examine on the
pod a ton because i think it's one of
those sites that i see i don't think i
know how big they are i mean like i
would imagine like not big like two or
three million a year in revenue but i
have no idea that's just a guess but i
know it's not big because they don't
hire a ton of people and
i was like this is one of the most under
monetized sites i've i know well i
actually think that their examine could
be significantly examined could be a
hundred million dollar a year business i
think
how how do you think
so there's a bunch of so i would i think
that they for one they don't do any
affiliates so something like wire cutter
you know wire cutter
uh so in um in new york times you know
they're a publicly traded company their
the wire cutter revenue got
classified now as uh like other revenue
so i've been trying to like decipher it
and figure it out and they do something
like close to nine figures in sales from
affiliate
affiliates examine doesn't want to do
that but i think they i think they could
i think they could do it a tasteful way
and it could work wonderfully because
what examine doesn't do is they don't
tell you which brands to buy but i think
they should because that's what i want
and that's what a lot of people want
additionally i think you could sell to
doctors so there's actually another
company out there that does like four or
five hundred million dollars a year in
sales and they sell to doctors and when
you go to the doctor and you have like a
rash they just like it's like wikipedia
for doctors they like look it up and
like the latest studies are there on
that
interesting and examine you know i
didn't talk to us all about that but
they don't want to do it because they
don't do they not want it to taint the
they want to become a review site i mean
that's why we don't trust review sites
right is that but i trust some i trust
wirecutter
yeah i mean i think i think there's this
way to solve for that like like dude
like if casey neistat is a youtuber who
i like if he tells me a cool product and
then there's an affiliate link there i
don't care that it's an affiliate link
right
but anyway
uh exam i also think examine.com could
work for injuries
oh like medical like hey my knee because
to get the definitive yeah this is that
or just illnesses in general right you
google symptoms and like rehab
yeah
are you sick or injured enough to make
that a thing that you would pay monthly
subscription for
not me well
i don't know i i don't know if you could
make money through subscriptions with
that but i do think that like when you
have like an achilles injury and you're
like i'm desperate i'll do anything i
just need to learn like because i
remember when i was researching for my
like i had a pain in my leg i was like
i like i went to all the studies and i
just read all the studies i'm like i'm
just going to figure this out i'm not
going to read like a how article and how
to do this i'm just going gonna go to
source and like what's the what's the
thing that i'm reading about the studies
but how does uh rob do you know how does
examine.com operate like how does that
literally work because all they do is
they like
pour through all the studies and find
the ones that have a good sample size
that have definitive proof and they make
a list of like these work for sure and
then they have another list that says
these seem like they might be able to
work but we can't say for certain and
then these are don't trust
pretty much yep and they
their big hit early on he said all this
on the podcast it was it was all seo
right it was organic and then they took
a google dive at some point i don't know
when it was but um they had already
implemented their subscription revenue i
don't even think that they had ads at
one point i don't know that they do
anymore i'm actually on the site looking
around but yeah that's it that's how
they write the topic and their
what is their value
it's the brand it's the trust
you know what i mean that's why everyone
goes to it because they have built that
brand that you you trusted and i trust
it but but how do they do that though do
they literally just have one hey go uh
all right editorial team this week you
steve your writer your writing topic is
um
um building muscles so go and research
everything that helps you go research
creatine protein
so if i were them i would be looking
they've been around for a decade now all
the topics have been covered i'm only
looking for new information right i'd be
monitoring all the journals all the
whatevers and have subscriptions to all
that i don't know exactly how to do it
but that that would be it right it's
having having a google alerts
essentially for all the new medical
stuff to just update you just want to
keep it updated that's crazy i can't
imagine there's a new topic they haven't
already covered in their thousands of
pages and this would actually make way
more money in crypto
totally i mean there's several
there's several niches where this this
would be interesting the hardest part is
there's a bunch of crypto news sites and
when i go to them i just don't know
i don't trust them yeah i don't know
like are these guys like these like
hardcore libertarian the world's gonna
end money like uh cash because
it's just stupid or it are that you know
like
a great way to explain it is like
basically do you remember like the mac
versus pc ads where there was like uh
like a cool looking mac guy versus a
nerdy pc guy and you remember that
animosity created between mac and pc
guys
now
imagine if each person who owned a mac
or a pc had a million dollars of apple
stock
that's like that's like the the that's
like the vibe that you're gonna get
that's right and it's religious fervor
with money behind it and so it's very
hard for me to hear a cryptic guy even
sean shawn's one of my best friends and
he but i know he's got a lot of crypto
so i'm like
but is this because you are you telling
me
what you want to happen or what you
think will happen right
so it's actually really interesting what
would you do to build that i would start
so first thing you have to do is build
credibility you have to start there so
i'd probably start a podcast
so that people could hear my thinking
week to week um i would definitely be
attending all of the crypto events
anywhere to get into the network to
build trust because if people don't if
you're anonymous like if you try to
build this anonymously no one's no one's
going to believe it so i would get into
the network and then
follow the model i would look at what
did exam and do we know anyone who has
done this model what did they do in
terms of
of uh
content and then obviously just hire
writers and
look at the white papers and give our
opinions
and this is actually a cool business
because this business could last a
hundred years
so like if you look at like um
consumer reports consumer reports has
been
around for a decade decades they still
do well into the nine figures of revenue
so consumer reports is a you know review
site that people pay money for they're a
non-profit so all of their expenses are
public all their revenue is public and
everything and they're still growing and
so like if you do a good job of building
a brand like on this topic and you start
reviewing stuff and you do a good job
you can review many other things and
last for a very long time it's kind of a
cool company
yeah
yeah they are still kicking
anything else interests you
i am interested in
i mean this you know normally i'm boring
bit boring businesses are my favorite
right because it's like b2b sas is is
the way to go um i think anytime you can
take a concept like we've said with
builder prime um you know where it was
just like crm for customers we have
another
company we funded called client hub
which is basically project management
crm for accountants and then we have
another one that's called gymdesk which
is basically run your gym business on
that it's like kind of crm and
communication so it's like where how
many niches are there where that works
some of these are going to be seven or
eight for your businesses some of the
niches are going to be very very small
um but that's where you just have to
pick it's like hey am i a lifestyle
bootstrapper because i want a 10 20 000
a month business um but i like these
ideas of
you know it it depends on your ambition
but if you want to
stay small and just build an incredibly
profitable business with two people
working on a you know 100 grand a month
i mean you can enter a less competitive
space if you want to grow big and grow
faster then you enter a space like
electronic signature or like calendar
scheduling links which we've funded
companies in both like calendly
competitor and you know and hello sign
competitor or whatever
they're a lot of competition you have to
move faster but the market opportunity
there is just tremendous
do you
what do you how do you decide if it's
going to be a eight figure
idea or much smaller is there a metric
that you look for
yeah
that's an interesting question i usually
so with tiny seed companies when they
apply we say
if your ambition is to build a
seven-figure
annual recurring revenue company then
you're in the right place we get some
people who say i really want just a half
million dollar business it's like great
that's going to be a great business for
you but that's not really fundable for
us it just doesn't make sense
um
i think a big piece of can it get into
the you know and we'd love to see mid
seven figures and up right
um
but a big question of can it get there a
lot of it it's less about market size
because most markets
are big enough there are few markets
that are too small most of it is uh
the metrics of the business is where we
look at the churn
and we look at the pricing
and so if you're if everybody's too
price sensitive to your point earlier if
everyone's a fly fisherman podcast and
everyone's paying you in you know 10 to
20 bucks a month and that's kind of
where most people are and then your
churn is 10 like
i you just can't you know almost
impossible to build a million two
million dollar business but when you get
to the point where hey my average
revenue per user is 100 or 500 a month
and your churn is two or three percent
you would have to own the whole market
like there's almost any market is big
enough that that can be a 5 million
business all right my last question um
how many of these folks building
software companies that you see
yourself included are non-technical
that's a great question and if they are
non-technical what do they do
yep
um so i'm a developer or it was i
haven't written code in years but we
actually at so we do a state of
independent sas survey and we put out a
report and it like an industry report
and
we asked the question
do you have
at least one technical founder right or
you know and yes or no right and
the number of
sas companies kind of bootstrap dish sas
companies with zero with no technical
founders
is like 20 i believe it's 20 percent 25
it's very possible
it is
and usually what the expertise they have
they're either the subject matter expert
like we're gonna build software for
accountants i was an accountant for 20
years right we're going to software for
ux designers i was a designer for 10
years they're either that or
they're sales or marketing
that's what they should have now we've
seen where there's a developer and then
there's like
the business person the business guy or
what just means it's like anything
yeah it usually winds up meaning you're
not actually that helpful and you
probably shouldn't be a co-founder you
know if you can't sell or market or like
have input on the product
yeah or or develop it like those are
really the four roles um
you probably shouldn't be
so if i'm if i like i'm not tech i'm not
technical but i um
i can like i stuff together and use
zapier and i'm super creative how do i
start a start a software company without
hiring or i would if maybe hiring zip
but without having a co-founder right
so for you since you have money you
would either acquire something because
there's always stuff for sale that you
may want to acquire and then just grow
if you have a content marketing
expertise or you would hire you know a
developer or an agency or something to
build it
if you don't have the money
uh a lot of people
non-technical will work a day job and
actually funnel money to the side to
basically pay for a developer to do it
um
the other two approaches i've seen are
exactly what you said which is i'm going
to build my minimum viable product using
zapier and
notion and chewing gum right and i'm
just going to cobble it together to the
point where hey if i get a few grand a
month in revenue this proves it and i'm
going to use that to get it built it's a
harder way to go but it's possible the
last one i've seen which is genius and
this is what the founder castos did
because he's not he's a single founder
not a developer he worked a day job
he started a productized service podcast
editing
and he hi he got it up to i forgot what
the number was 30 or 40 grand a month in
productized podcast he was one of the
earlier ones it was called podcast motor
he was working a day job the whole time
so then while he was actually doing the
editing or he would he did it first and
then and then got someone overseas
exactly yep yeah yep or even even has
folks in u.s and canada doing it um and
there was enough profit margin that he
then started reinvesting you know and
said well now i want to build now that
i'm doing podcast hosting he actually
was in the podcast space someone says i
have this wordpress podcast plugin for
podcast hosting on wordpress and i want
someone to kind of adopt it type thing
since he was doing something in public
they approached him he bought it for not
very much money and then he built the
entire you know what again is a
seven-figure business he's raised you
know three aside from us he's raised
three quarters of a million dollars and
it's grown fast so that's the other way
to do it is like i even i was a
developer and i had to do it nights and
weekends too you know when i was pulling
money away from the day job for the
agency and
hiring a developer what what's the best
way to do that do a lot of these folks
like a lot like when i was starting
everyone said like oh just go on odesk
and hire someone in india to do it and
i'm like i don't know man that doesn't
sound like i can like
like
yeah so like what are you
what what are there any agencies that
you like or for hiring devs are you
hiring someone by the hour in america
what's what do you typically see
yeah i typically see i see a lot of
people going either through referrals
like you get into a community um
microcom connect or indie hackers or
whatever dynamite circle and you ask and
you say who has used someone whom you
trust right so you try to get that
referral it's not just a flat look
because going to upwork which used to be
odesk is kind of a show these days
the other thing is there are now these
referral services aggregators there's
one called trust shoring which is run by
a guy who attends microconf but he
basically knows a bunch of eastern
european
dev agencies and if you come to him and
say i want to build an ios app he'll say
cool i have these three agencies that i
that i refer to he's almost like a
broker in a way but like he's a good
dude and he knows them you know and so
he and he's vetted them and then there's
one called clouddevs.com
and they do this similar thing for latin
america
and so
do you like cocktail or anything like
that
top towels good it's expensive um
right because i think it's under 15
hours so it depends on budget and all
that if you're if you're scraping by i
haven't used top towel but i've had
friends use it and i heard quality was
really good in the early days and of
course like anything it gets you know
less and less but um that's certainly
something you could try too how much
would you budget to create an mvp
it depends on what it is you're talking
like a sass app here's the other thing
man
if you're if you are non-technical and
you've never started a startup before i
would say don't build a sas app it's too
hard like go i have this thing called
the stair-step approach to bootstrapping
which is like start small with like a
wordpress plugin a hubspot add-on a
salesforce add-on a heroku add-on and go
build that cut your teeth at it's way
less expensive way harder to maintain
and way easier to maintain you get the
experience you get some revenue then
grow it to enough that you can buy out
just buy out your day job eight grand
eight grand a month maybe ten grand a
month then now you have experience you
can double down and um and do it
that's awesome
to your question of building an mvp of a
sas app
10 to 30 grand power to throw it out
but and you think a non-technical person
could actually maintain that and
understand what's going on
well no then you'd need to have that
agency sticker that's what i'm saying if
you're non-technical
um you either need some money i mean
this is why folks you build it
and you're you pre-sell it
you get to the point where there's
enough revenue that you can then justify
you know raising funding right
if you're if you're not technical or you
have a side job that's uh putting money
into it well thanks for coming and
talking about this i you have a good
view of what's going on in in this space
i think it's badass ben what do you
think
yeah that's great thanks so much for
coming on rob appreciate it absolutely
thank you guys i really appreciate so
good this is awesome um do you want to
give a pitch
where do people follow you most
so i'm on twitter at rob walling and
frankly they listen to this podcast they
would probably like start up to the rest
of us it's more focused on you know sas
and startups but
35 minutes every week for 590 episodes
that's badass i'm a fan i've been
listening to you for a long time almost
10 years it feels like thank you this is
awesome thanks for coming thanks so much
sam
boom
that's it
[Music]
you